hello I'm Jessica Clemens and welcome
back to New rockstars today I'll be
diving into Glass Onion and the Twist
and ending explained because this movie
was so funny and fun and I just have to
talk about it with someone because none
of my friends saw it in theaters yet it
was only out in theaters for a short
period of time and if you missed it
it'll be coming to Netflix December 21st
so be warned this video will contain a
lot of spoilers because I'm going
through the entire thing baby oh I love
murder mysteries knives out two AKA
Glass Onion brings back Daniel Craig as
our detective Benoit Blanc to solve a
seemingly easy murder Mr hear me out
like a Glass Onion it has a ton of
layers but once you peel them back it's
very easy to see what was at the center
the entire damn time let's start with
Duke what I liked about this murder
mystery was we actually don't know that
the first murder victim died days before
the movie even started it doesn't become
a murder mystery until Duke dies then
we're all freaked out it's revealed
later that mile swap drinks with Duke
knowing Duke is deathly allergic to
Pineapple killing him on purpose because
Duke's phone as the internet addict he
is is set to alert him about everyone in
the room along with his favorite hobby
so when the Press leaked Andy committing
suicide he used it as leverage on Mile
seen as one Duke is the only person that
saw Miles leave Andy's house the day
that she died two Duke wants his own
little news program on Alpha and three
he'd never tell anyone it'll be a secret
between the two of them which is a
stupid idea it's the holidays and lots
of us are going to be going to dinner
parties and none of us want to show up
empty-handed if you're one of those
people that show up empty-handed what's
wrong with you it's so easy for you to
get little things The Classy thing to do
is just bring a bottle of wine but I
don't know which bottle of wine to bring
and that's where bright sellers comes in
hand I got two right here bright colors
is the easiest way for people who are
curious about wine to learn what kind of
wines they love so they can share the
love of wine with people they love and
you can act like you're really smart and
you know a lot about wine like me right
so other times you take a quick seven
question quiz that will match you with
wines from all over the world especially
to match your taste which let me tell
you my taste is Rich after that bright
sellers will send you the wine directly
to you so you don't have to waste time
at the liquor store buying wines based
off of the label each package of wine
comes with wine education cards for
every bottle that Al online tasting
notes suggested pairing the best serving
temperatures you guys you can look like
the wine connoisseur along with these
ones bright sellers sent me tentra De
Luna and I know I'm pronouncing that
wrong but let me tell you buy the card
it makes me look really smart the info
card suggested using Manchego cheese my
favorite from Spain to bring out a
really robust flavor and it was spot on
easily a new go-to wine for me and I
love it if you rate your wines after you
try them your future picks will improve
so you can dial in exactly what type of
wine you like if you've got a follow-up
questions bright sellers concierge team
will help you with any questions you
might have you can just add me bright
sellers is giving our followers a
limited time offer 50 off of their first
six bottle box click the link in the
description and get started you'll be
glad you did just like me I'm double
fisting baby Andy and Helen are my next
biggest twist throughout the movie we've
been seeing weird red flags the flat
tire shoelace undone scene that was a
little too long The Stumbling down the
stairs from Andy the weird subtle
conversation each group is having is
revealed later once Andy is shot that
it's not really Andy who we saw at the
beginning and breaking open the wooden
box and hanging out on the island is her
twin sister Helen he's got Twins and
twins put that in there andy allegedly
committed suicide days prior and Helen
ain't buying it so she enlists detective
Benoit Blanc and like a Glass Onion it
makes perfect sense why you'd have Helen
pretending to be Andy one it would
certainly rattle the person who killed
you who's there two you could go and
give Benoit the invitation like he was
invited himself and then lure him to the
island three while you gain insight as
your sister you can help give Benoit all
the details no one will ever suspect you
but the killer who is too dumb to put
one and one together and say oh my dead
colleague is here and so is detective
benwell block I didn't invite him he
must be with her she must suspect
someone of killing her sister it's it's
so easy but miles is such an idiot so
then we get into this hydrogen disaster
how miles is creating a hydrogen fuel
AKA queer with a K I hate him that uses
sea water to fuel the world when they
sort of get into a Katherine Hans
character Compares it to the Hindenburg
now like miles Glass Onion and in the
house the Hindenburg exploded when
hydrogen leaked and mixed with the
oxygen from outside the ship along with
a spark which ignited the gas causing
the ship to explode with flames so it's
clearly a bad idea seen as people can't
even light a candle or make glass
you know how people just make glass in
their houses either way I don't know I
think I'll put that in there as a joke
now what's interesting to me is a
hydrogen actually burns with a light
blue flame it is nearly invisible during
daylight hours it could look more yellow
when there's dust or sodium in the air
since it's made from seawater the
hydrogen fuel Crystal that she throws
Into the Fire and they live on an island
that could be why the Flames were not
blue they were very bright and yellow
the only thing that irritated me is why
did the lighting of the napkin on fire
not cause a combustion but the giant
fire pit did maybe have something to do
with the amount of spark needed to make
it combust either way every home can
possibly explode if the invention were
to make its way into the right or wrong
hands okay so now we get into miles
Edward Norton gotta love em gotta hate
them unfortunately Benoit Blanc at his
finest point in the movie recognizes he
put the idea of how to get away with
killing Duke into miles head before
block suspected miles of being the
two-time killer he told him to be
careful he's crossed everyone on this
island and invited him here it's like
turning off the lights and placing a gun
right on the table which miles takes too
hard and literally does after killing
Duke leading everyone to suspect each
other and not him for a stupid guy he
did it in a lot of good ways he planned
a party so he could use it as a group
hang as an alibi for Andy's death
distracted us with Birdie's stupid dress
twirling he confidently misled us about
Duke and we believed him as most
billionaires he's very sneaky
controlling good and bad at putting the
blame on someone else and like the
stupid billionaire he is he hid the
napkin instead of destroying it and I
know all of us in the theater watching
this was like destroy them can you idiot
if we know anything about True Crime you
destroyed the evidence no one will find
it this napkin was the Holy Grail of the
movie it was Andy's original plan for
Alpha showing the alpha though she
co-owned it with Miles was more her idea
than his when the napkin disappears
miles won her share of the company
kicking her out with nothing later Andy
found the napkin threatened her old
friends to come clean or else she would
use it as evidence which scared miles
into killing her so he wouldn't be found
out now a normal murderer again would
get rid of the evidence but not this one
he hid it behind a Fibonacci Sequence
which we see as one of the games you
have to solve from the wooden boxes in
the very beginning with a red spot in
the same place as the one in Miles Glass
Onion harboring Andy's Red Envelope he
wanted to be caught the entire time
luckily miles realizes he needs to
destroy the evidence once confronted
with it by Helen he sets it Ablaze no
one's on nothing right the [ __ ]
continue to be [ __ ] alas detective
Benoit Blanc knows when he's been beaten
and raw satin until he puts into her
head Helens suggestively to burn the
place down to the ground with the
hydrogen cell he tossed to Benoit
earlier that he never gave back so like
I said earlier fire plus hydrogen is a
big No-No once everything things on fire
do you feel like you won do you feel
like Helen Warren do you think
everyone's been a bench of course not
that is until we see the beautiful
rented out Mona Lisa behind its safe
prison destroy it Helen that's that was
me in the theater I was like yeah
destroyed as soon as miles bragged about
his Fail-Safe release button I was like
oh someone's gonna use that and destroy
it another Glass Onion moment and
rightfully so Helen opened it allowing
it to be consumed in Flames I say
rightfully so because I love payback so
let's talk about the Mona Lisa real
quick for storyline purposes I love the
justification miles rented the Mona Lisa
due to covet cobit did halt tourism in a
lot of countries and those
tourism-dependent countries lost a lot
of money France lost a good chunk of
money and now does the Louvre really
loan out its most prized artwork
absolutely not but like Beyonce and ape
[ __ ] you can rent out the place it can
cost you upwards of 34k so I mean like
you got that money go ahead and you can
send it my way but this shows just how
ridiculously Rich miles is and a lot of
the rich Antics billionaires will do Mel
hear me out is burden the Mona Lisa okay
is it a great way of getting back at
someone absolutely not but in a setting
where no one saw anything this
billionaire trying to double cross
everyone just to set fire to the world's
most prized piece of art with his
hydrogen cell
yeah that won't look great plus he'll
lose all his money plus he'll go to
prison no one will know it was Helen but
the [ __ ] and Miles the group will
hate him the insurers of the paint dude
will hate him France will hate him the
world will hate him he'll be penniless
jobless and without his Island home
after he gets out and I love it let me
know in the comments what you thought
about Glass Onion if you'll be seeing
the third one because I know I will I
thought the movie was so fun I actually
genuinely liked it more than the first
one and I loved the first one so I
didn't think it was possible bring me
more murder mysteries you guys I love
talking about them and I want to talk to
you about them follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
but before you before you go this Sunday
at 10 30 a.m we'll be performing at La
Comic-Con we'll have the description
below and the link to go get your
tickets come check us out it'll be me
Tommy Brandon Eric Voss um Zach I think
I'm missing someone and I hope I'm not
either way thanks for watching let's all
be remembered in the same breath as the
Mona Lisa
[Music]
thank you
[Music]